[Music]
guys Rainbow six siege is a shooter with
a heavy emphasis on tactical gameplay so
it's perhaps no surprise that the
attacking side often has to be pretty
methodical with their game plan most of
the time the aggression brionna's
finally working against him mr. boss is
ready to play the angle get the kill a
smooth kills from both teams mostly g2
though as Kanto gets to farming it's
another enemy we'll fight back though
with two of his own running out wild
outside of the front door Fabien is down
and the round is one for Penta what what
we just witnessed that's why this week
we're counting down the top ten rushes
in Rainbow six siege now guys when we
say a rush we're not talking about mid
round execute like you're seeing here
we're talking about plays where the
objective is overrun in less than a
minute so let's see some of the fastest
gameplay our six has to offer with the
top ten rushes in Rainbow six siege
[Music]
starting our list off at number 10 is g2
eSports who showed supremacy no respect
during their pro league match in a game
that saw a two chauka pick an
interrogation and multiple spawn Peaks
the French squad were clearly outmatched
by G 2 even with ping who sidelined
regardless of how g2 are playing such a
struggle for supremacy right now and to
close out this mean fest of a game g2
decided to barge in with no less than
three shield operators and though they
may have been delayed by a few traps the
rush was well and truly on Farrell moves
in with a ballistic shield and there you
go p.m. Em's the Jews who goes down
alive the whole reef rack and of course
this Fabien down Goga has walked in and
gotten one mono alive Cantrell Kenny was
a refract again onto Anthrax's shields
all right into him and he can't do
anything against the techies will go
down gogo and the finisher on the Monti
and k-6 will go out of the round
sure would have thought it g2 will meme
their way to another win and I guess at
number nine is a perfectly executed rush
where the defuser was planted 27 seconds
into the round with a season 9 Pro
League spot on the line elephant gang
decided it was time to turn up the tempo
in their game against noble esports and
with no way to rotate back onto the B
site noble were wiped out without
trading a single kill
she's quicker speaking of quicker
Neptune's gonna be rushing into the site
here and we'll try to deny the well push
in through the smoke that's been
established the fuser being implanted by
the Maverick of avian Neptune's name
we'll find yet he goes also takes out
passive with a beautiful one tap in the
main lobby crazy will be downs easy now
the last defender and he has to retake
in a post plant it's not gonna happen
go shuts them down what is going on
again a Russian through delivery and now
a 3-1 lead our number 8 rush comes from
a Latin America Pro League match with
the defending faze clan quickly at a
position as bootcamp gaming planted the
defuser and with lions gadget online
phase had absolutely no chance for a
retake I'm guessing it's gonna be
something different the only thing is no
heart destructor is like you said so I
guess the main lobby rush okay does all
the way in now he's in sight he does not
check laundry all the way so he gets
shot from his flank the prone does not
work anymore like that duds but Paula
gets double kill behind the ash so who
can't have the control that they also
wanted thanks to a well-read rush in
through the main lobby stairs and Kings
gonna get a stroll on the flank and the
defuser is going down it has finally
been planted evil eyes still alive but
not able to deny that plant map gonna
have to call his phone and Gohan gonna
have to stand still in just a second as
the EE 1d is you
a nice strategy being employed here from
boot camp and it is all but impossible
for faze clan to fight it back em King
and attacked lock it up and excellent
execution from BK our number seven rush
brings us back to the Oregon basement
but this time sees ronan esports on the
offense against evil geniuses during
season seven of na pro league i imagine
that this is going to be a very fast
round no matter who waits as blitz led
the charge for ronin EG were quickly
overrun and wiped out before the defuser
could even be planted canadian goes down
and here comes the rush ronan already
inside of laundry forcing these
defenders back as the mirror windows go
up young through the wall will get the
kill the cookies reciprocates as he
pushes through the main hallway and
ronan for the first time looked like
they have a chance and their own
dominance in this match this is a
wonderful cheese trap that we see right
now but Yugi is able to come up hill
board eliminating neck rocks and the guy
takes it out rode in one that took 45
seconds and that route is over leave it
to Ronan to just bulldoze inside of the
site they're coming in at number 6 we
have a rush that took place on day 1 of
the Paris major g2 executed the ideal
strategy for Oregon's basement and
market esports found themselves at a
numbers disadvantage with the diffuser
ticking down left all alone enemies echo
stood no chance against g2 s four
remaining members down they're not even
gonna take this rushing they realized
the entire site is empty because
marketer playing this latin america
style everybody off the site that's the
first one getting taken down it's boy
now the second one is well Penghu down
on two alive 3b two of the diffusor
already planted panics low on health
against one kill on jana the Goga will
refract reveron is down on the floor up
top in the meeting hall and it's all up
to enemy as the mp5 SD will make him
hurt moves in through the hallway the
ashcan coming from the back and it's
already Goga
finishing off course TV and having down
revin upstairs in the meeting hall more
than enough jeetu beautiful at number
five is a rush that sees mantas FPS
makes some questionable decisions
regarding their defensive setup during
the six Invitational a pack qualifier
with no mantas players playing on-site
wonka led the charge on Ashe and quickly
cleared a path to the objective giving
the attacking team an advantage that the
defenders should have had they're
rushing the thought they know it's clear
they're just gonna head right on down
and there's nothing to stop them right
now oh my goodness look at this one cut
just it gets into the start completely
uncontested no there were a little bit
too confident there right and then sit
up there there you go first kill he's
gonna be coming out Wolcott does manage
to find sweep like there on this site
now and now it's up to Mentos to try and
retake it their work themselves out they
ever got themselves in the foot for sure
what a brilliant fast push there from
Norah Ringo cloud is gonna be able to
find one no time finds the next one and
well mantas only have one left new yo
he's gonna be going down pretty soon
surely cloud does manage to find only
Chan but yep there we go walker finding
new yeah and that was cool aggressive
play styles you talked about those
monkey first I mean you know I barely
loaded into the map before we saw what
happened they're bringing the best of
both raw firepower and tactical prowess
g2 eSports showed off an excellent rush
strat in our number four play against
team vitality during a pro league match
at this point teams were still learning
consulates new bomb sites and g2 took
full advantage of the site's vertical
placement and well we all know what
happened next
this is match point this could be over
very very fast they're just gonna sprint
right in and cut through the site cleave
right through vitality but doesn't look
there's anybody on site don't get a
plant off with that 30 seconds vitality
so committed that no vitality everybody
is still alive the good news is that
this is still winnable for vitality but
they'll retake and all the sites will be
on all the various members Fabien Goga
Penghu can we see canto and yonas pick
up chills just to left here for vitality
brigand get the first one for his team
though as Penghu goes down watching the
VESA flank the fire bolts in the back
hall are going to prevent any potential
pushes but gogo will also take out bread
leafing spark and 1 vs. 4 and he has no
time our number three spot is a rush
that sees fnatic on the attack against
the defending little geniuses in the
quarterfinals of pro league season 8
fanatics ash and Habana took out 3 EG
players within the first minute as
Canadian scrambled back to the site
unfortunately he ran into a claymore
along the way
leaving Gio to die in the retake I think
it's a big difference there is red
starting on for the first kill and then
bless you with a second that seems to be
working out for ya they walk in and they
switch around to the bearing 9 as
rooster eyes will get one more Canadian
to trade off finally it's got utility in
hand and to umps to try and retake this
in up-close battles it's way too
complicated
Canadian ball walking into the Claymore
of aces Oh get shot down gioco
he'll find that shot it'll be enough
fnatic will take two rounds now on the
attack the runner-up spot on our list
goes to a rush that see psycho live up
to his namesake as he showcases the
iconic ash rush with absolutely no
regard for fanatics defenders during the
Paris major and though it came down to a
1v1 in the end the sledge was able to
clutch it out in the after plan looks
like a rush it's gonna be a rush cycle
is already in kill see Eiko easy goes
taking kills both style as well he says
I think there's no one to hold this push
twenty seconds and they're in the R is
res will answer back
do they have complete control so I go
we'll get one magnet we'll trade it off
and magnet with another the lesion just
unprovoked defuser goes down
raagh will watch gzd will get a kill of
his own and kneel fighter last man
standing but he's getting pinged he
knows the marks he gets the down on the
vog and easy to his last man left bug
will not be provided enough you need to
be a living drone as he will get taken
out himself but pzd is there to close it
out and that round was over before it
even started
the zelphia ash combo to fall open the
castle barricades combined with the EE
1d nothing fnatic could do there at all
except wait to die and nipple Regan and
Kalina
[Music]
coming in at number one is a rush that
not only sees Team Liquid take the top
spot on our list but at pro league
season 7 as well down again but up on
rounds in their series against Penta
liquid decided to turn it up a notch
with a quick execute into the workshop
and server room the castle bought little
time for Penta as the ash took out a
wall and three players within the first
minute against both a lion and a doe
kabhi Yunus was left with no choice but
to concede the round looks like a
complete down push here for bathroom
team look not gonna get a lot more
aggressive than expected here wow what
the lack of the smoke they're gonna get
him yes
next we'll take him out liquid are
running away with us here getting a kill
each as they're using the top of the
service through third base
finally nestle and the headshot on Kanto
is very low on health this plane from
topside it's bullet taking down Pangu
all on us and this is working the rush
plate from liquid has been perfected and
Penta did not expect this one here is
the fuser is no bullet will take down
the onus what a fantastic bit of
execution
such a beautiful attack execution they
dip the drone in they looked into how
the defense was set up and said you know
what this is weak ok guys that's our
list for this week now you know what to
do next
rush down that like button and the
subscribe button and comment in under a
minute
for more great Rainbow six siege content
and I'll see you next time thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]